we are learning new details about
another deadly encounter with police
this time it's in columbus ohio
where an officer killed a 16 year old
girl now police body cam video released
hours after the shooting
shows that micaiah bryant was holding a
knife hundreds of people marched to the
ohio state house in columbus yesterday
to protest
our lead national correspondent david
begno has a crucial 11 seconds of video
before the shooting
you have to know before you watch it
it's graphic it's very disturbing to see
we'll play it for you again this body
camera video shows officer nicholas
reardon arriving at the scene
he asks what's going on and then
riordan fired four shots at mikaya
bryant
who police say was armed with a knife
and was about to stab that girl in the
pink
she had a knife she just went at her
here's the 911 call that led police to
the scene
girls over here trying to fight us a lot
of people have said
couldn't he have just shot her in the
leg so she dropped we don't train to
shoot the leg
because that's a small target rounds
miss
and then they continue on and there are
people behind that that could be in
danger
paula bryant is michaela's mother this
never should have happened
she's a loving girl you know within six
hours of the shooting police released
this video which is unusually fast
this rapid response comes after the
death of andre hill
he was an unarmed black man who was shot
and killed by officer adam coy four
months ago
coy did not turn on his body camera
until after he shot hill
and he never rendered aid to him he was
fired
charged with murder and pleaded not
guilty now compare that to this shooting
where three responding officers had
their body cameras on when they arrived
and they started performing cpr almost
right away
these cameras and the footage increase
accountability on both sides of the
camera that's the columbus mayor andrew
ginther he campaigned
on a promise to implement body cameras
and the department started doing it back
in 2016.
this week for this shooting he pushed
for the footage to be released
were you worried that it might be too
risky to do that jeopardize the
investigation well i trust the public
and i trust this community
and i think what's most important is to
be transparent as possible particularly
when you're dealing with a very high
profile
shooting involving a 16 year old child
the officer who fired those fatal shots
is on paid administrative leave this
morning that's pretty customary
after an officer-involved shooting and
anthony you know here in columbus
it's now an order for police officers to
turn on their body cameras for every
call doesn't matter if you're going out
on an emergency call non-emergency
you have to have it on yeah and columbus
clearly has responded with transparency
david thank you